well we've been waiting to figure out
how much of a disaster or paradise the
Republican health care proposal would be
we've been waiting for that
Congressional Budget Office report on
the Republican health care plan and we
have it and it is an unmitigated
disaster we the we looked at the House
Republican plan to replace the
Affordable Care Act and it turns out not
surprisingly to many people that it
would increase the number of people
without health insurance by 24 million
by the year 2026 now for comparison the
Affordable Care Act Obamacare led to 20
million more people obtaining coverage
of course many of those because there is
a mandate which says you must have at
least some minimal coverage plus 20
million under Obamacare minus 24 million
under the american health care act put
forward by Republicans way worse off a
net loss of 4 million insured and as
Rachel Maddow astutely tweeted this is
like the populations of Vermont Alabama
North and South Dakota Delaware Montana
Rhode Island Maine New Hampshire Idaho
West Virginia Nebraska New Mexico Kansas
and Wyoming combined losing their health
insurance the budget office also
estimated that 52 million people in
total would be uninsured in 2026 under
the House Republican bill compared to 28
million projected under current law what
about premiums average premiums for
people buying insurance on their own
would be 15 to 20 percent higher next
year in 2018 as well as in 2019 than
they would be under the current law the
Budget Office said but after that
premiums would be lower than expected
under current law around 10 percent
lower in 2026 the budget office said now
that doesn't mean that they would be
lower than now because premiums are
projected to continue increasing and
increasing and increasing but they would
be 10 percent lower than the current
projection for that year just as big of
a story and this is not being discussed
too much is that it will
save money this plan will save money but
it's not much money it's three hundred
and thirty seven billion dollars over
nine years
that's only thirty seven billion dollars
per year in terms of government spending
and savings this is not a lot of money
considering that we spent for example in
the 2015 budget nearly six hundred
billion dollars on the military two
hundred and twenty nine billion dollars
on interest on the federal debt this is
not my commentary on the debt that
that's a separate topic but just stating
a fact of what the numbers are Donald
Trump promised everyone that they would
have coverage and that if you couldn't
afford it you will have it paid for by
the government lies lies lies and here's
a completely serious question I'm not
being facetious or sarcastic which will
lead to more deaths in the u.s. if this
bill passes people not having health
care or Muslim terrorists coming from
other countries into the United States
that's a real question I don't know the
answer to that the White House obviously
immediately denounced the Budget
Office's conclusions which makes no
sense whatsoever recall that under
President Obama Bureau of Labor
Statistics data about jobs and
unemployment was fake and phony
according to trump and his buddies now
we have identical data I talked about
this yesterday for February and now
Donald Trump is cheerleading the data of
the Bureau of Labor Statistics same
thing the CBO a nonpartisan Department
which scores and evaluates the financial
impact of government proposals Trump now
doesn't like the numbers so he claims
that they're bogus and here is where we
get to the sort of bottom of the barrel
the real bottom feeders human Health and
Human Services Secretary Tom price of
the Republicans this is the guy who
seemed to have the closest thing to what
we could call plan for the six years
during which Republicans just tried to
repeal repeal repeal Obamacare
Tom Price was one of the guys that had
the closest thing to a plan to replace
it he was asked about this report from
the Congressional Budget Office saying
24 million will lose insurance it's a
disaster he said the report is offering
an incomplete picture be
it isn't taking into account the
regulatory steps that he intends to take
as well as other legislation that
Republicans plan to pass as part of
their multi-step strategy to repeal and
replace the health care law what does
that even mean what Tom Price is
suggesting here is that Republicans are
also going to cut out regulations in
ways which we don't yet know it's a
wacky funhouse mirror we just don't know
what reality is and it's gonna
completely change the circumstances so
that 24 million people will not actually
lose coverage and I guess we'll save way
more money than the paltry 37 billion a
year he said quote we disagree
strenuously with the report that was put
out well I'm convinced folks Paul Ryan
focusing on the premiums being lower in
ten years part ignoring that premiums
would be higher for many years saying in
ten years premiums will be ten percent
lower than the currently projected
numbers which of course will be still
way higher than they are today
truth is we can't really project that
accurately ten years out and 10% lower
than expected in ten years if true it's
not even particularly impressive okay
now one's talking point that it's
important to debunk right now many
Republicans are saying well listen David
some of those millions of uninsured are
going to be uninsured by choice because
it's young people who never wanted
health insurance under Obama care anyway
they're healthy and they are now going
to be able to exercise their
individualism and freedom and not be
forced to buy insurance by a bogus
federal health care mandate that's true
some of them are healthy and they will
be fine but many won't and will end up
using the emergency room as their doctor
when they get sick many will never pay
because they'll get a huge bill and
that's all going to be priced into the
premiums that people who do have
insurance will pay and that's going to
drive premiums up and that's going to
include people who need health insurance
and can't afford to pay more who will
have to pay more because so-called
healthy young people will get sick at
least some of them there is an
alternative okay
because the real discussion shouldn't be
whether we have a a che or a CA the real
discussion should be that our entire
health care system is morally bankrupt
there's something called HR 676 the
expanded and improved Medicare for all
Act sponsored once again by congressman
john conyers a democrat from michigan
introduced on january 24th 2017 fewer
than two months ago the bill establishes
Medicare for all to include everybody in
the United States it would destroy the
for-profit health insurance market
because it says that health insurers may
not sell health insurance that
duplicates the benefits provided under
the bill insurers would only be allowed
to sell insurance for benefits that are
not medically necessary like cosmetic
surgery and the program would be funded
from existing sources of government
revenue for health care by increasing
personal income taxes on the top 5% of
income earners by instituting a
progressive excise tax on payroll and
self-employment income by instituting
attacks on unearned income and by
instituting a tax on stock and bond
transactions call your elected officials
tell them specifically I support HR 676
I will vote you out if you don't support
HR 676 you can go to who is my
representative dot-com to find out who
your representatives are call email
every single one of them